time waits for no one
with every tick of the clock we get
older and inside our cells
a kind of molecular clock is ticking too
marking the inevitable process of
cellular aging
i regard aging as a medical condition
it's a decline in function
leading to suffering and in many cases
death
david sinclair wants to turn back the
clocks in our cells
and he believes his latest results from
a series of experiments on the eyes of
mice
suggest it might be possible to reverse
[Music]
aging
in 2012 shinya yamanako won the nobel
prize for showing that you can take an
adult cell
say a skin cell grow it in a dish and
put in
four yamanaka genes yamanaka factors we
call them
and convert that adult cell into a what
we call induced pluripotent stem cells
stem cells are like black cell templates
from which all other types of cell can
develop
they're essentially the youngest a cell
can be so we know we can take an adult
cell
back to h0 this is a stem cell but if
you do that in a person you
this would turn into a tumor so what you
want to try to do we try to do is to
take the age of the cell
to a certain point where it's young
again but not so young that it loses
its identity and we had a lot of trial
and error
mostly error eventually david's team
found a combination of
three yamanaka factors that seemed to
turn back the clock just part of the way
in cells in a dish the next step was to
try it out in a living creature
but for that they needed a way to tell
if their de-aging process
was working when you damage the central
nervous system in a very young animal or
an embryo
it can grow back but in an adult it's
impossible
so we took older mice and damaged their
optic nerve just by pinching at the back
so normally those axons would die off
and the mice would be blind
instead we saw with our three gene
reprogramming combination
the optic nerves started to grow back
and eventually
did grow back all the way back to the
brain the nerves were regenerating
but that wasn't all david thinks
something even more fundamental
is going on one of the hallmarks of
aging is epigenetic change
these are changes to how genes are
switched on and off
so when we're young our epi genome is
pristine it's set
with genes on and genes that are off
that maintain a cell's identity
and this pattern must be maintained
throughout life
for that organ and that tissue to work
optimally
one part of this epigenetic pattern
involves chemicals called methyl groups
that attach to the dna
as an organism gets older the pattern of
methylation
changes we can use these dna methylation
patterns
to make a clock a dna methylation clock
also known as a horvath clock
that estimates your biological age and
when david looked at the methylation
clock of the mice in his experiment
the patterns had changed according to
david
the clocks had turned back and the cells
looked younger
which told us that we weren't just
protecting these nerve cells
we were literally reversing their age
bolstered by these results
david and his team turned to more
conditions associated with age
they tried the same experiment in mice
that had become blind due to old age
and in mice with artificially induced
glaucoma an age-related disease that
damages the cells of the retina
they gave the blind mice the three
reprogramming factors
and then tested their vision we could
put mice
in front of a screen where lines are
moving
and if a mouse is blind it will just sit
there staring
but after we treated the mice what
happened was we saw that they were
starting to move their head
like this in response to those lines
showing
that they had got their vision back and
that as far as we know is the first time
that's ever been possible as before the
mice didn't just regain their vision
their cells also appeared younger
according to the dna methylation clock
not only that but when david's team
experimentally fixed the methylation
patterns
preventing them from changing the blind
mice
didn't regain their vision which
suggests to us
that the clock isn't just a measure of
age
it's involved in the aging process and
even in its reversal
david and his team are keen to try out
the three reprogramming factors
on other kinds of tissues and eventually
in humans
to see if they can reverse age-related
conditions like glaucoma
but there's still more work to do to
understand exactly how
these three factors are able to make a
cell
functionally younger again the fact that
we can reset the age of a cell and make
it functional again
and have the right genes turn on and off
as though they were young again
implies that there's a template a store
of information that's useful
much like a backup copy of software that
we can reset
the big question really is where is that
information stored
where is that template how does the cell
find it during this reprogramming method
and this is one of the most important
questions i think that now needs to be
solved
we don't know if the template to use
really is hidden inside each of our
cells
but if david's right perhaps a cure for
aging
isn't as impossible as it might have
once seemed
you